*Disneycember theme*
It's The Suite Life of Zack & Cody the movie yet again another movie based on a show I didn't watch and if this movie
is any indication of what the show is like I think it's pretty obvious why I did watch it.
The suite life starts off by ironically having nothing to do with suites. In fact it's actually on a ship
I'll just assume something happen in the show to make that happen.
Actually it's a little weird seeing how Zack and Cody aren't
technically in the title of this movie only the suite life is and yet there's no suite in it so honestly this entire
movie is a complete lie. Regardless Zack and Cody are identical twins
but one of them has a problem he won an internship to get into Yale,
which means he can't hang out with his girlfriend for a bit.
She gets pissed off splitting up with him and to make things worse his smart aleck brother messes up his internship getting him thrown out.
But it looks like the scientist
he was working with has another internship for him one that involves no surprise twins.
So they're both sent to this lab that
experiments on twins to see if they can create a certain fruit where the more you eat it the more you can feel each other's
pain grow empathy and eventually become one mind. But wait isn't that a bad thing? Well yes.
it is when we discover that the scientist actually has evil plans to turn all twins into one hive and
force them to take over I don't know the world.
It's kind of a weird plan for kind of a weird movie. So the biggest problem with this film is very obvious
it's not funny, but I don't think it's supposed to be funny to me.
This is funny to the same crowd that liked to say Good Burger like little little kids.
One of the earliest jokes they have is mishearing mammal for camel.
Mr. Mosbey: Actually London their not fish their mammals.
London: But they don't have humps.
And if you didn't laugh of that, I'm sorry, that's what they think is the best joke in fact
they do it four times in the film.
Mr. Mosbey: Their not fishies their mammals.
London: Then why don't have humps.
The movie is mostly filled with humor like this and actors that aren't bad, but are good either.
It's slow clunky awkward, but again
I think it's that way because it's mainly aiming for a little little children to be watching it.
And yeah, you might be arguing don't our little kids deserve better, and yeah sure, but at the same time
there's nothing really harmful in this.
I'm not watching this think it's like Camp Rock 2 where there's actually a bad message or bad ideas being thrown by.
It even once in a while gets a little bit of a giggle. Like the delivery from the mad scientist is legitimately well-timed.
Yeah once in a while the girlfriends delivery can get a few laughs.
Everything else is just kind of what you think would be done with this concept
just kind of slow and not funny
But I'd be lying if I said I couldn't see an audience of little kids watching this and having a fun time.
Is there anything in it for adults? No is there anything really that great for kids in it?
No, if nobody sees it is anyone gonna miss out on anything? Probably not, but nothing is gonna be made worse by saying it either.
It's like a sock puppet show there's nothing really to it, but what's there really to get angry at either?
It's hitting the right crowd and not making anything worse.
I know that's definitely not a glowing recommendation.
But what can I say this movie didn't leave that big an impact on me if you liked it you're probably the exact right age
group for it, and if you don't you're probably the exact wrong age group for it.
I guess I could be angry and say kids deserve a lot more, but honestly it's just not worth the effort.
It's Zack and Cody it's stupid, but it's painless. Take it for what it's worth and just be happy
it's not Cheetah Girls. If you think that's the best thing I can say about it
you're right.
Later